hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
möchte euch heute eine kleine übersicht
über die messen in diesem jahr geben
die letzte messe auf der wir waren warte
gold messe in friedrichshafen
da gibt es auch morgen noch ein video
dazu da haben wir nämlich ein rezept
direkt vor ort gedreht und ja einfach so
ein paar bilder von der messe das gibt
es alles morgen und in diesem video
möchte ich einfach sagen wo wir denn
dieses jahr noch alles sein werden also
die rtl und auch mit dabei deswegen
redet jetzt auch mit sein buch in der
hand und liest geht es kein baby update
morath nimmt die l
ja auf jeden fall ist die nächste messe
die also eigentlich wäre die nächste
messe in dortmund decade and bike das
sind wir dann auch vom 28 bis 29
denn leider nur zwei tage aber der
messestand ist echt riesig also wir
hatten letztes jahr immer so um die 80
quadratmeter messe dieses jahr waren es
murat und in dortmund den 800 euro 300
oppositionelle einer fast eigene halle
genug platz haben und weil in
friedrichshafen haben sich ja es war
halt ziemlich voll und in hamburg wasser
schon voll friedrichshafen war noch
voller und ich glaube in dortmund ein
großes einzugsgebiet wird wahrscheinlich
noch mal voller und deswegen schauen wir
natürlich auch immer dass wir immer mehr
platz haben
ich meine wir haben sie auch zum letzten
jahr ziemlich verbessert also letztes
jahr hatten auch verbessert weil wir
hatten letztes jahr einfach nur so meist
nicht kennt jetzt dass diese manuellen
kassen die man so in einem vereinsheim
hat weiß wo man das kennst du das muss
mein taschenrechner daneben stehen und
ja dieses jahr hatten wir dann
wenigstens zwei kassen dass es alles
schneller geht und ihnen dortmund wird
natürlich noch mehr also wir gucken da
schon dass es eben auch für euch sehr
komfortabel ist aber wir müssen jetzt
selber auch mitwachsen und jetzt hab ich
eine ganz große überraschung aber nicht
immer zum schluss also in die nächste
ist wie gesagt die kick-back am 28 29
zum ersten mal genau mit dem report
ich freue mich auch schon dann kommt die
hannover messe vom 15 bis 17 oktober da
freue ich mich auch schon darauf denn
letztes jahr
und ich eine teilnehmen weil die ela da
noch immer bank war und es war kurz vor
meinem geburtstermin und das ist die
kate burns und dann gibt es noch die
kreativ messe in stuttgart und zwar ist
sie vom 17 bis 20 11
da freut sich der rat darauf nach
familie geburtstag endlich auch fast wie
bei uns hier also stuttgart ist eine
stunde von mir und ich bin auch sehr
gerne krise müsse mit über 120.000 genau
und es ist auch da gibt es auch ganz
viele andere messe stellen also ist eine
richtig tolle messe und jetzt gibt's
noch und dann sind wir noch anfang
september in berlin auf der ifa
allerdings nicht mit meinem eigenen
stand sondern wir sind dann zu besuch
dort aber das sage ich euch dann noch
bescheid weil ich nicht weiß an welchem
tag ich da sein werde
und jetzt gibt noch eine messe und sah
wirklich alles negative sagen was
passiert ist okay das schlechte und dann
das gute tut mir echt leid aber die
weinmesse dies leider abgesagt tk world
weil einfach die die messehalle viel zu
teuer ist und sich das für diese rufe
wie genau ausstellung also für die
aussteller für die messe veranstaltet
und es rechnet sich einfach nicht echt
viel viel viel zu teuer und deswegen
können wir leider nicht hinkommen aber
wir suchen natürlich schon nach einer
möglichkeit wie wir trotzdem nach wie
ein kurioses
vielleicht seid nicht traurig irgendwas
für ist auch schon kontakt in manchen
leuten genau versuchen um die location
zu finden mehr nach wien zu kommen oder
nach österreich zu wenig wieso nicht
aber es ist eine chance und mit ihnen
über die schweiz habe auch schon
gesprochen genau damit auch hat jemanden
kennengelernt auch auf einer messe auf
einer messe gehe sei das los die ist ja
noch in zürich sind ja also das schauen
wir mal aber da gebe ich auf jeden fall
bescheid
ok jetzt habe ich wieder die stimmung
und zwar gibt es noch eine messe und
zwar bei uns hier in waghäusel
wir haben jetzt nämlich die möglichkeit
bei uns im globus-markt da ist eine
freie fläche und da bauen wir unseren
messestand auf das heißt wir haben eine
messe im globus drin und der eintritt
ist komplett kostenlos also dass ich ein
einkaufszentrum sage ich jetzt mal noch
und da könnt ihr dann hinkommen und die
wird sein
das wird nämlich jetzt die nächste messe
die mit vom 17 bis 21 5 sein
also von mittwoch bis samstag genau das
richtig drauf weil es statt heimspiel
ja so ist es naja lassen alle unsere
freunde unsere familie dann könnte man
durch mag heute durchlaufen und
gemeinsamen mahl unsere stadt sehen und
viel kostenlos wir natürlich backen
kochen ja wer ist noch da kennt ist
dadurch mit dabei da mag es vielleicht
ist sie dabei
ja also darf ich mir schon richtig drauf
das heißt das ist jetzt die nächste
messe in waghäusel dann kommt dortmund
dann kommt hannover und dann die kreativ
messe und vorher natürlich noch die ifa
messe ich glaube das war's oder war es
17 18
also mittwoch mittwoch geht's los gehen
mittwoch bis samstag genau könnt euch
jetzt aussuchen was genau es samstags ja
auch alles noch eingenommen wie bildung
als eine information gibt es generell
website genau da könnt ihr übrigens
immer schauen also wir haben da die
kategorie messetermine und da könnt ihr
immer rein schauen da steht dann auch
immer alles aktuelle und so weiter
ja ich glaub morath jetzt können uns
verabschieden wir haben hier weiter
drehen denn ich bin gerade mit dem dreh
aber ich wollte ich natürlich bescheid
sagen und ich freue mich auf eure
besucher und ja wir sehen uns dann als
nächstes in parkhäusern
bis bald und gewalt komme auch oma und
da freue ich mich letztes mal war ja in
meine tante dabei meine cousine und die
frau von meinem kopf stellen wir immer
das der familie kommt in dortmund kommt
meine cousine sogar mit und wie gesagt
instruments nachhinein spiele ich dass
uns extra krachen ja richtig lustig
vielen dank